hello guys I'm Ryan writes and I'm Jerry
Jerry we're good Todd's a cat Todd is
named after the Fox and the Hound
character Tom and this movie happens to
feature a fox segue we're talking about
Zootopia we are talking about Zootopia
I guess I'll just start with my feelings
I just want to be very genuine because I
thought this was a very genuine film
yeah I purely loved it but it - I think
if you want to talk about a film an
animated movie that'll move your
emotions this is that I cried I think
twice I was getting misty a lot during
this movie
everything about this film works yeah I
saw it twice actually
I saw it in 3d the second time the 3d is
pretty good too but from the very
beginning this movie is establishing its
art types and cliches yet it's also
going against it like you get the
parents of judy hopps
they're unsupportive but they have great
intent in how they talk to her this
movie does a great job on it so [ __ ]
deep it's like too deep for me to handle
well this movie does a great job of sort
of confronting and at least discussing
discrimination of almost every kind
totally because this film Wow Wow I'm
like realizing stuff Azzam as we're
filming right this movie is just so damn
good see what this movie doesn't so
great as it uses like an allegory of
animals it goes back to that like you
know kind of like Animal Farm when we
make a movie about anthropomorphic
animals we can slip in very progressive
ideas yeah we'll just be like it's
animals and it does a great job on
tending to modern day topics that are
serious issues in our society oh yeah
and it does it as such it does it from
beginning to end whether it be about
this Judy Hopps character who is
fantastic by the way Jennifer Goodwin
plays are immediately a relatable
upfront because one thing that's I I've
thought is very present in our society
is how parents think realistic for us
it's a lot of the time and then they
don't really they stop encouraging you
at a certain point to really like just
go after your dreams and you could be
who you want to be okay I'm saying all
parents do that I'm just saying a lot of
parents have good intent oh yeah because
they're trying to protect you from yeah
from a bigger meaner world than you
might be aware of and it's nice to start
a character that way cuz like I feel
like a common territory for animated
movies is sort of the character who
wants to do the thing that no one told
them they could do and that's a nice way
to jump us into this
because it slowly kind of comes out that
like probably every character is on you
feel like every characters on that kind
of an experience where somebody held
them down and this is why life is this
way exactly exactly and to take the plot
of turning it into like a cop movie was
and brilliant because that is the
perfect excuse to go explore Zootopia as
well to really see this world they've
created and it's a beautiful world it's
like I'm watching I'm like this is
[ __ ] magical it made a lot of sense
as a society which was which was nice it
seems like they thought it out cuz like
you know the good dinosaur just came out
from Disney / Pixar and that was kind of
an issue with that movie I was like how
does this society exist though cuz they
have like different technologies you
wouldn't be able to make it like this
feels like a fleshed out you know actual
world going back to the cop thing that
they made it a cop movie but also like
almost like a film noir style like
detective movie like it's not a cop
action movie they're like on the beat
getting Clues you know investigating and
it was just a throwback II kind of thing
that I thought was nice there's a classy
vibe about it yet the film does go down
some rather dark territory Brit Disney
film especially especially now yeah this
seems like they're actually like putting
some chips on the yeah I'm gonna be like
hey you know we're here I saw this movie
twice and there's one moment and both
screenings were the whole audience jumps
the core of this movie and beyond its
themes are the characters but the
characters represent such strong parts
of the themes you know like they're a
great representation of what this movie
is really trying to tell us about and
Jason Bateman that was like the
voiceover role he was meant to play yeah
man it is it is though me Jason Bateman
could have done that role that role is
like perfectly suited to his exact
characteristics I kind of get tired
seeing Jason Bateman play like [ __ ]
Jason Bateman like he has lately this is
one where I was like it's the perfect
level yeah I like this guy he's not a
dick but he is you know kind of a shady
dude yeah yeah yeah and he brought so
much charisma to that you know as he's
it was called utopia and the whole world
is animals there's no humans and a you
know like is in life we say that humans
are animals at heart you know we see
that we're also animals so to see these
animals depicting humanity was a real
trip you know like it's a version
yeah it tripped me out more than when I
watched inside out honestly yeah yeah
well because it's so much bigger there
are so many more moving parts to think
about it have so many options for how
you can lay that out until that's right
beyond the themes the visuals are
fantastic there they are like the yeah
well there's chase sequences anytime
they're exploring the world I'd love how
they like you explore different
ethnicities of these animals to
different species different races yeah I
put scale of a town they have like a
giant city for the big animals like a
medium-sized city a tiny little gerbil
city it brings in other physics to
consider in life it's very creative and
thought-out like they think about how
would this animal you know how would
they get their food how would they
travel like this how would they work do
they they think about every single
animal there it's so [ __ ] funny like
I cracked up so much and that sloth
seemed and everyone you know like raves
about you know from just the trailers I
don't care that they showed in the
trailer because I watched it twice and
both times I've watched it I've cracked
them so much what I think that's all the
benefit is showing a scene that way is
like then it can become a highlight
you're like oh I can't wait for that
yeah you know cuz there's more context
yeah like most trailers give you like a
good joke or a dramatic element you're
like when's that beat but having the
seat was just like it was a treat when
it came back around and I was like yeah
you know and there are other characters
that I feel like that are not really
being talked about
mayor lion a lion heart Jamie Simmons
yeah I thought he did a great job for
that role you know like JK Simmons is a
scary guy he's playing a lion however
because he has that natural toughness in
his voice but he's playing someone more
caring it was a good balance for that
voice you know well yeah he has a lot I
don't know what to call that quality but
it's not even that he sounds tough it's
just like he sounds like he can take
care of himself he still molds into like
yeah I had this guy's you know a
politician he's the mayor or whatever
but yeah I still would want to make this
guy upset he blends into the role really
nicely cuz he's one of those few guys
who's like you only kind of recognize
his voice but in a way that's not
distracting or just like he's playing
himself and I thought Octavia Spencer
was really good too like yeah there
bringing Octavia Spencer in when they
just need something dramatic yeah yeah
Tommy Chong made a cameo you and I
thought he had a great cameo yeah love
what they do with this cameo yes
beyond you know making fun of the stoner
image and well some adult jokes in there
too like the hole modestly seen yeah and
who I really love those Nate Torrance as
a clown sir oh that's right yeah he was
[ __ ] oh he was hilarious oh and and so
sweet like yeah happy cheered up at one
point I was like buddy as far as more
themes go there you know like it does
deal with issues of like every type of
discrimination like you said racism
sexism I had a debate that it dealt with
what we've you know experienced in the
community with homosexual with
homosexuality being a genetic re Prius
was predisposed to being homosexual
interesting you know and oh because they
were talking so much about this is in
their biology oh okay yeah you could
definitely draw that parallel I don't
know if it's an exact when you can draw
yeah yeah and some people were talking
about like marijuana references to it
goes beyond racism it gets raw to the
point where you're like this is really
talking about some serious but dolt
stuff yeah cuz I mean like I heard
whispers it's like Oh surprisingly
progress him especially about like
racism stuff but like there's everything
there's like workplace discrimination
and status and age discrimination it's
definitely going into a restaurant yeah
you know even the way it's not
necessarily like discrimination but even
the way that you know like you said
before like parents try to kind of pass
these things along to their kids and
stuff like that like there's a whole lot
of stuff going on I feel like the
characters partly are so good because
you kind of have to develop them to make
this work at all you got to think okay
you know lion in what like who's he
prejudiced against and and does he know
it or not you know now a rabbit who was
she be president against in Hawaii and
it forces them to flesh these characters
out and and it makes a very real feeling
world you know what - it does it makes
you care more about animals you know
like it makes you go
you know what all animals really are
unique themselves you know like each
individual animal because we're because
we're so used to just going animal just
like every other one other kind you use
your animal and you think Oh outside and
you don't have like Oh different habitat
different conditions different roles
yeah munity like giving it up bringing
in affects them and which it does you
know we've seen it in dogs and cats of
that I have at least Oh totally well and
I'm you know I was really late on it
there's no certain level of hierarchy
yeah yeah I've like I've been really
mean to one dog I saw how he responded
he became a total dick oh yeah then I
got another dog and I treated him with
love and compassion and he just gave it
right back so I realized that if you
don't want your dog to be a dick to you
don't be a dick to your dog yeah same
thing with your cats
don't be a dick to anything well some
things you got I mean you should care
about the dog regardless shouldn't just
be about not making the dog to be a dick
you should just care I'm not making not
being a dick it's just a nice byproduct
a humane exist man I feel like when
people are giving criticism of this
movie sometimes it sounds like to me
that they're just looking to give
criticism of things because there was
one point in this movie where I'm like
is this movie about to end oh okay this
is like a good point and and then kept
going oh yeah like for another half hour
but it wasn't like this movies dragging
me you know it was still essential and
important and it makes the story's that
much better but then I look back when I
second time I saw it I was able to see
the structure of the film better yeah to
me that felt like a necessity because I
thought it was ending at a certain point
I was like no it can't be it's not been
that long but it feels like it's ending
and then it kept going and for me it was
like a oh good like oh good like there's
more to it than just this all these
messages and stuff might sound like if
you haven't seen the movie and you're
just listen to this review they might
sound like well I've heard other movies
do that before what this movie does it's
so good is attends to kids in the
cartoon way which is awesome because
there's
wrongly communicating these messages
that are not just important for kids but
also for adults hence you get a great
family film it's the way it treats its
stuff to that's unique to me is like it
doesn't feel very painted in like Oh bad
or good it's like it allows its main
character to make some understandable
but poor choices about you know the
people she's talking to in consorting
with and it kind of does that for
everybody even though you know who your
protagonist is and all that no one is
totally you know impotent but yeah no
one's totally impotent for all those sex
scenes but I didn't feel like this movie
was like beating me across the face of
the message because it just felt like it
blended with the society they were
telling it happen it felt genuine and
natural like you yeah like that's what
sets it apart
they created a world in that world they
told a specific story that was in effect
to the rest of the world it was great it
was fantastic movie and also giving it
to children in a way that's not like and
here's the moral of the story like it's
just a movie you know can't wait til a
porn site makes an animated sex of
Zootopia oh it's probably already
happened people make a lot of money
selling really yeah keep a lookout for
that reaction I give this movie five
pause yeah oh and I give it live like
six hundred Jerry's guys are near the
channel subscribe to the real rejects
yay yay yay yay reasons to Jerry is a
playlist of him and dank ass dubs has
his voice Jerry show us that voice me me
me me me me me no what do you want me to
do you want me to get real close I just
wanted you to talk normal you know what
hey man I'm not your your you know
puppet you can just make dance around
you're an angry drunk you're an angry
human being human being you're a little
real that's in Zootopia Oh